Best known as the young golden haired woman living alongside humankind's closest
relatives.
This scientist,
turns activist,
has devoted her life to understanding and working to save chimpanzees from near
extinction.
How Unorthodox methods of observation revolutionized how scientists conducted
animal reception,
the wild,
deep,
long held assumptions about primates behavior and showed the world how much we
have in common with the animal kingdom.
Let's learn more about the legendary British primatologist ecologist,
anthropologist and UN messenger of peace.
Jane Goodall,
Mary Jane Morris.
Scoodle was born in London,
England on April third,
1934.
She was the oldest of two girls,
born to farther mortimer and engineered race car driver and two mother van,
a successful novelist exactly four years following Jane's birth,
a younger sister,
judith was born and completed the family.
This API force and note it would be short lived with World War Two.
You declared in England in 1939.
Jane's father enlisted and was posted to France.
From then on,
he would become a distant figure in Jane's life only.
Rarely coming home when he was on leave after the allies declared victory in the
war was over.
The good old marriage ended in divorce a few years before Jane must have known
it was coming.
The youngster wrote a heartfelt letter to her father,
pleading him to wait until she was 12 years old.
The divorce of Jane's parents,
method of greater impacts on her if her mother hadn't been such an influential
and supportive parents.
Jane says it was her mother primarily.
This encouraged her to live out our passions,
saying,
Jane,
if you really want something and if you work hard,
take advantage of opportunities,
never give up.
You will somehow find a way.
My mother would later play a role in Jane's early career,
traveling with Jane and staying on the camp,
but the Gombe Reserve.
Jane spent the majority of her childhood growing up in her maternal
grandmother's 18,
72 victorian house in the resort town of Bournemouth on the south coast of
England.
They had a yard with a garden and trees were.
Jane spent most of her free time surrounded by women.
Jane shared the residents with her mother,
sister,
grandmother,
and two aunts.
It was a happy home and a place good old now in her eighties,
goes back to when she needs to relax and recharge.
She says all my childhood books,
the trees.
I climbed as a trials,
the cliffs where I walked.
I'm blessed in this way.
Young Jane Develops in early fascination with wild animals.
Just over a year old Jane's father,
gifted tyree lifelike,
three foot tall,
stuffed chimpanzee that she affectionately named jubilee and carried around with
her everywhere.
Jane's Mother's friends were quite horrified by the toy chimpanzee fairing.
It would give the young toddler nightmare.
It's quite the opposite,
though.
Jane loved the toy and she still has it.
Over 80 years later being that Jane devoted her life to researching and saving
chimps,
the only gift of stuffs chimpanzee seems like the ultimate foreshadowing,
but Jane admits she is keen on all animals and would have studied and other
species if the circumstances had been different.
In fact,
as a go,
Jane did not limit herself to learning about just one kind of animal.
Jane would often be outside the family home and the yard quietly observing,
sketching or writing notes about birds and other creatures have.
Family had a host of pets,
including a tortoise and the dog and the young Jane,
so can many more including racing snails,
caterpillars,
the lizard and the canary.
Jane was an avid reader to some of her favorite books included Dr doolittle.
Tarzan in the jungle book.
Reading these books ignited a desire to go to Africa someday to observe and to
write about wild animals.
Jane was also a curious and patient young step once when Jane was five years
old,
her parents could not find her errands,
presumed to missing.
As panic ensued in search began.
It turns out to Jane had been sitting in the hen house waiting for the chickens
to lay eggs.
This quiet observation and persistence is the hallmark of our good old would
later conductor research at gone best stream.
While Jane entertains fanciful thoughts of Africa and long to be outside in
nature,
she was still a young.
I'm enrolled at the uplands private school.
By all accounts.
She was a good students,
but felt the routine of the classroom unbearable.
At 16,
she confided in her diary writing,
woke up to be faced by yet another dreary day of torture,
that gloomy place of discipline and learning where one is stuffed with education
from days dorn today's Eve,
despite these feelings that she managed to embrace us school studies and
finished strong focusing her interests in biology and English.
She even won two prizes for essay writing in 1953 and at the urging of her
mother Jane and in the London's Queen Secretarial College and graduated one year
later after receiving a qualification,
Jane held clerical jobs in Bournemouth and Oxford University.
She also sometimes waited tables and took a part time job with a film company
still.
Jane never gave up on her dream of going to Africa even if the idea seemed far
fetched.
In 1955,
Jane Goodall received a letter from Khloe and old school friends with an
invitation to come to Kenya.
The day had finally come.
It was the opportunity that she had been waiting for.
She saved hard for the fair and in March of 1957,
embarks on a three week journey by ship.
Soon after arriving in Kenya,
Jane took a job in the capital city of Nairobi and demands of the famous British
paleontologist Louis liekly,
who was then the curator of the Natural History Museum.
The museum,
Jane at this point was just 23 years old,
leaky assertive Charles Darwin's theory of evolution and believed humans
originated in Africa.
He was motivated to find the missing link and we're searching for just the right
person to study primates in the wild rather than in captivity.
Researcher vapes in their natural habitat has not been carried out before in
this manner and leaky soar in Jane,
the perfect candidate to conduct the study not only need to Jane exhibit the
enthusiasm he was looking for,
but she also had the temperament to sustain long periods of time in the African
Bush with a mind,
uncluttered and unbiased by theory.
Up until this time,
good old has no formal scientific training or academic credentials that
qualified her to conduct such a study.
Not to mention women scientists who are practically unheard during the 19
fifties and sixties.
Nevertheless,
Blakey took a chance on the young woman first hiring her as a secretary and then
sending out to the Gulf stream reserve in Tanzania in 1960.
Jane was on her phd later in 1965 from Cambridge University.
The degree it would earn Jane respect to the fields and an hour to receive
funding for research
in 1968 at the age of 26 Jane Google Inbox for the gun best dream reserve now
part of the Gombe National Park in Tanzania,
Uganda is bordered by the longest lake in the world,
Lake Tanganyika in the Goma region of the country in 1960.
When Jane began her research,
the forests have gumbo the parts of a continuous chain throughout Burundi,
Rwanda and Uganda and scratched Westwood's toothy Great Congo Basin.
Jane's destination was only accessible by boat and as the land was characterized
by steep valleys and lush green rain forests,
the African Bush and waters were alive with many species of wildlife,
birds and fish today and remains one of the best places on earth to observe
primates in their natural habitat.
Goodwill's mission was to learn everything she possibly could about the wild
chimpanzees.
Arlene gone back.
Her mother accompanies her on the trip for the first few months.
The local authorities believing a young British woman would never survive alone
in the wilderness.
Bops labeled right though the dangers of nature were less of a concern at the
time.
Civil war in the Congo had flooded with refugees for several weeks.
Jane,
her mother runs one.
Kirk were forbidden to travel to the stream and waited out the conflict in a
prison camp until it was safe.
Again,
thinking back on her first Dang gone bear.
Jane recalls looking up from the shore to the forest,
hindering the apes and the birds and smelling the plants.
I'm thinking it was very,
very unreal.
Jane's early attempts at getting close to chimpanzees failed.
She could get no closer than 500 yards.
She found another trip and established a pattern of consistent observation by
appearing in the same spot each morning along the stream near the chimps feeding
area.
It was one male chimpanzee who allowed Jane within close range.
She tempted him with your banana and named him David,
graded for his white tufted chin.
Once does allow Jane to get close and to watch him.
Other members of the group started to feel comfortable and accept our presence.
No other human up until now had ever gotten so close to chimpanzees in the wild.
It would take two years for the chimps to show no fear of her and she was
allowed to observe them almost as if she was a chimp self.
Jane imitated them,
eat their foods and spend time in the trees.
She would become closely acquainted with over half of the 100 or so chimps in
the reserve.
Much of the horror of some scientists,
Jane gave all the chimps names like flow,
Fifi,
Flynn's and Mr Greg Hall at this time.
One was careful not to give human characteristics to animals for fear of
engaging in anthropomorphism.
Researchers tended to use numbers instead,
good old would later recall,
these people were trying to make ufology a hard science,
so they objected.
Choirs unpleasantly to my naming,
my subject sand for suggesting that they have personalities,
minds,
and feelings.
Critics aside,
Jane continued to practice.
She believed that empathy was the key to detecting slight changes in mood or
attitude,
and those changes could provide insights into complex social processes.
Within weeks had gone bad,
Jane was making new discoveries in turning conventional thought on its hat,
making tools and using tools was thought to be an exclusive traits of humans and
not animals.
Yes,
Jane witness David graded using a blade of grass to extract termites from a
mountain stands on another occasion.
He stripped leaves from a twig to gain better access to his prey.
This was the first recorded time in history that another species how to used or
modifying tools leaky.
It was so excited.
He famously exclaimed,
we must now redefined man redefined tool or accepts chimpanzees as human.
He was surely exaggerating,
but the discovery was a major blow to the notion of man the toolmaker.
A few weeks after the toolmaking revelation,
Jane observed David [inaudible] eating what looks like a piece of meat.
It was a piglets,
and so the long held theory of primates as strictly vegetarians swelled.
That was also debunked through Jane's observations,
the world would also learn chimps,
engaging cannibalism and warfare.
Jane witnessed a brutal four year war with a neighboring tribe that devastated
the chimps.
MAILCHIMP's also routinely patrol the borders of their territory and will attack
a solitary male chimpanzee from another tribe in order to protect their area.
This dark side of chimpanzee behavior,
Jane Goodall likened to gang activity living amongst the primates.
Jane observed that chimpanzees have complex brains and social systems.
The caste system of chimpanzee society places the dominant male at the top,
which is often ranked by how intense his performances at feedings.
Over the course of her research,
Jane discovered chimps to develop long term bonds with each other have
ritualized behaviors and even a primitive language with 20 unique sounds.
Chimpanzees possessed individual personalities and communicate through touch and
body language.
They kiss and embrace each other,
give pats on the back,
shake their fists,
and engage in a whole variety of other nonverbal ways.
Jay noted the males do not play an active role in the family.
This is simply left up to the females.
Jane observed the strong bond in the mother child relationship and it's found
that maternal instincts are taught not inherent.
Chimpanzees learn through observation,
imitation,
and practice the chimpanzees with good mothers who were above all else
supportive ended up being good mothers themselves.
The ones who were poor ended up having female offspring that was also poor,
mothering Jane even theorize that chimps may have a sense of self and perhaps a
spiritual connection.
How research concluded that mother centric groupings along with sex,
food sharing and grieving all the essential components of chimpanzee society.
Good old publication.
The chimpanzees have gone bad.
Patterns of behavior is the definitive work on the behavior of chimpanzees.
It would have become the core body of work used to establish chimps,
gorillas,
and had been as hominids.
The only discoveries of toolmaking and meat eating chips and the idea of young
woman living in the jungle caught the interest of national geographic and in
1962 they sent it to the dashing Dutch photographer Baron Hugo Evon Loueke to
film her work,
fell in love while on assignments,
and as they were in 1960 for three years later,
they had their son,
you go junior,
who she called Grub life,
seemed idyllic for Jane,
doing what she loved most,
being with and writing about chimpanzees and that were expelled.
This good old lens,
the wild chimpanzees ad in 1965 and thrust Jane under the spotlight and that
same year Jane received her phd from Cambridge even though it was his idea and
he pushed Jane to pursue her doctorate.
She acknowledged it was important saying that Cambridge taught me to think in a
scientific way so I could stand up to people.
It taught me to think logically.
I loved it and I loved analyzing the data.
It was a very important part of my development.
Jane and Hugo's marriage lasted a decade and my 1974,
the pack called it quits.
They remained on good terms.
She had married Derick Bryson member of Tanzania and parliaments and director of
Tanzania national parks the following year.
They had five good years together until his death in 1980 from cancer.
Jane was devastated by the loss,
but she came to terms with us.
I went to Columbia and the forest is very healing.
You get this endless cycle of living and dying and things fell into perspective.
In 1971,
Jane Goodall published one of our most popular and well known books in the
shadow of man.
A vivid description has brought the chimps to life and bridged the gap between
science and entertainments.
Jane published many more books after she able to professorship at Stanford
University and was appointed honorary visiting professor of sociology at the
University of Dar es Salaam in Tanzania.
In 1977,
Dr Goodall founded the Jane Goodall Institute,
Jay g,
I with a mission to protect the chimpanzees and further the research had gone
back.
These soft spoken Jane seems and unlikely celebrity,
but she would find her academic respectability and its popularity and advantage
when speaking on behalf of the chimps that she so loved over the course of our
research at gone,
bears became increasingly clear that the wildlife there,
including the chimpanzees,
were at significant risk.
In fact,
by the 19 eighties,
chimpanzees were an endangered species.
Their home and resources were being destroyed at an alarming rate.
After attending a conference organized by the Chicago Academy of Sciences in
1986 to coincide with the publication of the chimpanzees have Gumbo.
Goodwill found herself at a turning point at 52 years old sounds.
After 25 years of field research,
Jane wins on the road to educate the public on the vanishing habitats,
the bushmeat trade,
animal trafficking,
and the unethical treatment of animals used in modern medicine and for
scientific research.
In 1990,
the revelation came that Jane must turn her attention to humans in order to save
her chimps.
While flying over gone there,
she saw the hill stripped bare.
By deforestation,
the local villagers were responsible having over farmed their lands.
We've listed options left,
they'd taken the trees and the national park to sell his timber in order to
survive.
At that moment,
Jane realized that unless you address poverty and to work to improve the lives
of villages,
you can never expect to conserve the lands and save the wildlife.
She explained everything is interconnected.
You learn that in the rainforest.
Soon off to the Jgi launched programs focused on education,
family planning,
water management,
sustainable agriculture,
and microcredit for women.
Thanks to,
uh,
work with the Jane Goodall Institute's Lake Tanganyika catchments,
reforestation and education projects.
The Gomberg chimps now have three to four times more forest than they had 10
years ago.
Oh,
welcome.
The ethical treatment of captive chimps that the medical community to steer away
from the using cross species organ transplants,
also known as xenotransplantation.
Further goodall has made strides to phase out the use of chimpanzees and medical
research.
Council works tirelessly an average of 300 days per year to spread the mission
of the Jgi.
The institute has offices around the globe with programs primarily in Africa to
involve the local people in community centered conservation and other
initiative.
The roots and shoots program is an operation in over 130 countries and works to
foster environmentalism and peace among the world's children.
Good old passionate fight to preserve the welds.
Chimpanzee population has included service on the save the chimps sport,
the world's largest chimpanzee sanctuary,
located in Fort Pierce,
Florida.
Over a long career,
good all became the world's expert on primates.
Per field work has led to the publication of numerous articles and five major
books.
She has also written a number of children's books such as grubbed,
the Bush baby chimpanzees I love and my life where the chimpanzees,
countless people over multiple generations.
I've gotten to know her work through the National Geographic magazine,
television programs,
and imax film,
Jane Goodall's,
wild chimpanzees,
Jane and new documentary film by Brett Morgen was released in 2017 to critical
acclaim and features over 100 hours of archived national geographic footage.
The trailblazer,
Jane Goodall,
is still captivating audiences all this time later.
Good old has received numerous honors and awards,
including the gold medal of conservation from the San Diego Zoological Society
in Nineteen Seventy Four.
The J dot Paul Getty Wildlife Conservation Prize in 1984,
the Schweitzer metal of the Animal Welfare Institute in Nineteen Eighty seven,
the National Geographic Society Centennial Award in Nineteen Eighty Eight,
the Kyoto prize in basic sciences in 1990,
the National Geographic Society,
Hubbard Medal for distinction and then exploration,
discovery and research in 1995 and in 2002,
she was named messenger of peace by the United Nations in 2003,
she became a dame of the British empire.
And in 2006,
She was honored with the 60th anniversary metal of the UNESCO and French Legion
of honor.
She also holds multiple honorary doctorates from various prestigious
universities around the world.
Jane's research continues at the Bombay Stream research center established by
good old in 1965.
It is the longest running study of chimpanzees the world has ever seen.
The center hosts visiting researchers and continues to further our understanding
of chimpanzee health group dynamics,
diet,
and more.
The information gathered here can also inform conservation efforts.
These days dream visitor center at least twice a year,
but all the trips screen you have now passed on.
Jane's legacy is more than that.
Contributions to science or her activism,
how to termination and body of work inspires us to believe in ourselves and
remember our connection to nature and what we leave behind.
She wants us to think about the future and our role in protecting us.
Saying,
I care passionately about nature.
I care passionately about children.
I have three grandchildren.
I think about their children.
If we can't do things differently,
what is the world going to be like in 50 years?
Above all else,
Jane has taught us that it is up to us to make a change.
Every individual matters.
Every individual has a role to play.
Every individual makes a difference.
Only if we understand what we care.
Only if we can.
Where we help?
Only if we help shall we will be saved.
The least I can do is speak out for those who cannot speak out for themselves.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday won't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the race,
and as always,
thank you for watching.